I immediately just started crying and
maybe dropped a few f-bombs it was it
wasn't like really it's gonna happen
right now the night before this this
can't happen so but everybody it was
beautiful because everybody the cast and
crew just showered me with love and just
gave me positive vibes all night
essentially that's the essence of what
the musical is so it was touching last
night during our performance in front of
a live audience one of our cast members
sustained an injury a visit to the
hospital confirmed that Brendan hunt our
Roger has broken his foot and will be
unable to perform tonight
most of what you'll see tonight will
come from last night's performance but
we have all rallied together to rework
the final act so that all of us
including Brennan and the original
Broadway cast of rent can perform it for
you live well luckily for me it happened
after we finished what you own and we
were running for we have a four minute
commercial break and I have to Jordan I
have to run all the way across kaftan
down two flights of steps and so we were
going full sprint went down one flight
turned the next fly and when I jumped
off to take that left turn to go change
my foot just rolled over and it just
snapped I am so so glad that it hit we
had it on tape I just couldn't say that
enough that everybody gave us stellar
performance on Saturday and and and I
was very moved that they allowed me to
come out and perform you know in this
splint and you know just readjusting
everything for for my situation so I
just I'm very pleased with how it all
turned out I just wanted to reiterate
that to the people who watched that was
a live performance not edited it was
just it just happened to land on
Saturday and not and not Sunday and so
the producers decision to have me out
and show the cast and just embrace it
and give the the viewers and the fans of
rent a little piece of live action was I
thought it was beautiful
touching personally
[Music]
they got to see a very unique live
concert experience we had screens
everywhere so they could watch the
actual live broadcast while we performed
along with it and we played around with
each other and moved around different
parts of the stage it was very very
touching and very beautiful and they got
they got all of that on film as well and
what happened last night was essentially
rent in real life I mean because we all
do love each other and we're all a
family and we just came together and put
on a show for that audience last night
a lot of happy tears I've been pursuing
this business a long time and and
everybody's just super proud and and I'm
very proud of the work I've put in and
and just I'm just gonna leave it at that
I know it's unfortunate for the next ten
weeks I got to be in this thing and I
can't put you know wait on it but you
know it is what it is and I took a
sacrifice and we finished it somehow
[Music]